So today we’re going to look at bromine.
So this is bromine, it’s a small
sample, about 2 or 3 grammes.
Bromine is a red liquid. There are not many
elements that are actually
liquid: caesium, mercury, gallium and bromine.
It’s this beautiful red
colour and it has an unpleasant smell. Bromine
comes from the Greek
word bromos which means stench, a really horrible
smell.
In fact this bromine probably comes from near
where I did my degree
because in Europe, the second, well the largest
producer of bromine in
Europe is the Octale Company which is based
on Amlwch on Anglesey
which is where I went last weekend. So it’s
a nice sample. We’re going to
get it out of this bottle now because it’s
sealed in because it’s obviously
very, very volatile as a liquid and we’re
going to cut the glass, get it out
and look at its chemistry. Thanks Neil.
Bromine is also quite a common element in
the world. It is found in sea
water as bromide, it’s also found particularly
in the Dead Sea between
Israel and Jordan where there are very concentrated
solutions of
bromide. So you can make bromine just by bubbling
chlorine into a
solution of bromide like Dead Sea water and
the chlorine displaces the
bromine and forms chloride and the bromine
just comes out as red
fumes which you can catch.
So Neil’s now using a glass knife to open
the ampoule and he’s going to
pour the liquid bromine into this small evaporating
dish inside our fume
hood. Now instantly you can see the vapour
of the bromine coming off.
You see all those really nice orange fumes
which are coming off from the
liquid and then they’re being drawn away
by our fume hood.
Bromine has a number of uses, it is particularly
used in plastics as an
additive to try and make them less flammable.
If you’re watching your
videos on a screen which has a plastic surround
almost certainly that
surround will contain bromine to make it less
flammable.
Bromine itself is strongly oxidising so we
thought we’d do an oxidation
reaction today. And that reaction is to take
another element and here we
have aluminium, simple aluminium foil, like
you wrap your dinner in, and
we’re now going to put some small amounts
of aluminium foil into the
bromine liquid. So we put it in and it generally
takes a few moments for
this reaction to start but as I said, the
aluminium is strongly oxidising. It
oxidises and generates aluminium tribromide.
Which is a beautiful nice
material but it’s a strongly exothermic
reaction. So let’s see what
happens. This may initiate.
It is also an unusual element because elements
have different isotopes
these are the same form of the element but
with different numbers of
neutrons in the atoms so they weigh different
amounts. Usually you get
one isotope that is very common and another
one that is only a small
amount. Bromine is unusual because it has
two isotopes 79 and 81 which
have almost equal quantities in nature so
that they have approximately
51% of one and 49% of the other which is really
quite unusual.
So here we see the exothermic oxidation and
formation of aluminium
tribromide.
So the reaction is strongly exothermic which
means it gives
out energy and that energy then evaporates
off excess bromine which
you can see coming off as a vapour. A wonderful
exothermic reaction:
very, very fast, very, very rapid forming
aluminium tribromide.
Bromine is quite dangerous but it is less
dangerous than chlorine because
it’s a liquid at room temperature. Chlorine
is a gas so if you let out
chlorine it disperses everywhere. With bromine
it is a heavy gas which
can disperse rather more slowly.
So now as the reaction cools down we can see
that the volume of
bromine is significantly reduced.
Reacts with water quite well.